Sorry, I said the rash question too soon. I also have other itchy rectal
and vaginal as well as much as you'd all over even where there is no rash. I
take a daily detox bath baking soda, have some salts, charcoal, essential oils,
daily plus coffee and it wasn't soda. Could this be a histamine reaction and what
should I do about it? I would, I know you're going through a lot of stress
maybe stress is that is the main issues your needles are just fried. I know let's see let's go
back to this supplement list. So what would you do if somebody's, if somebody's
needles are fried? Okay, it's a medical term. You use adaptogens, it's the first thing you go
to is adaptogens, you know somebody would say, if you're on a deserted island and you've only
take one supplement with you, what would it be? Well, adaptogens would be right up there.
Big canoe of herbivorene would be a problem if they were in medicinal mushrooms but adaptogens
would be right up there at the top by. And the reason why is because adaptogens help balance your hormones.
If they're too high, they bring them down. So if you're, so there's different levels of adrenal
stress. So if you're under, you know, acute stress that you've had healthier
adrenals, your cortisol could be very high. That could be very dangerous. If you had a long
term stress, your cortisol and your adrenals could be just just toasted and your cortisol and your
epinephrine, your epinephrine are just really low. Well, wherever you don't need to, you know, need
to do a adrenal profile to know what you're at because if you just take adaptogens, it'll bring
your high cortisol down and bring low cortisol up. So let's just look real quick here. If you have
or take it, you have adaptogens in your list here. Well, baca is an adaptogen, but it's really
mainly an adaptogens for estrogen. That's a really good much for your adrenals.
So lute thiode is good if it is from radiation.
And I think we addressed this how to take it into proxide or early last week.
You really aren't on any adaptogens. So getting a good adaptogen would be in order.
Our, we have multiple adaptogens and we have multiple adaptogens, private labeled.
Either are adaptive clear or our court of clear would be good choice.
And adaptogens the way you dose it, I have people that take adaptogens and they're taking like nine
pills a day until they get through their stress. Well, you know, they can then you necessarily don't need
to take them. So adaptogens are something that you necessarily take every day. Adaptogens you use,
like you would use a medicine or under a ton of, a ton of stress and it issues that you take a lot
of adaptogens and then when things calm down and you're not under that ton of stress, then you
do put them in your cover till you only use them that you need.